the second session of the day uh we're
very happy to have
uh ramon van handle again from princeton
he's giving the third lecture of his
course on the discrete queue
all right thanks nike so i'm just going
to continue where i left off
but in some sense this lecture we're
actually finally going to get to the
point okay
what we've been working towards um so
let me remind you at the end of the last
lecture
uh where we left off is i had um you
know i've described our aim we're
thinking about vector valued functions
on the discrete cube
and um we would like to prove this
linear to non-linear principle that i
described which says that if you want to
have a punch
inequality for nonlinear functions on
the on on the discrete cube
what we hope is that we can have a
principle that says well if we know on a
given norm space how linear functions
behave
then we can have a punch inequality that
reflects that behavior of the linear
functions right that was the goal
but it's not even clear how to formulate
this thing so what we did is we made a
little detour to the gaussian case and
in the gaussian
case we have this very beautiful theorem
of pca which i discussed in some detail
last time and i gave a complete proof of
it
and you see the way it works is that the
expected expected norm of the
nonlinear function minus expectation to
the power p
is bounded by some universal constant
times the norm of a linear function of
the gradient of the
um of the function f and this linear
function itself has gaussian
coefficients and so if we understand how
linear functions of gaussians behave on
the norm's space
then we can upgrade that to a much more
general statement about nonlinear
functions
so this tells us what we aspire to and
i'm not going to say more about the
gaussian case now because we discussed
it in depth last time
but this clearly tells us what we aspire
to right we aspire to prove such a thing
on a discrete cube
so what should such a statement look
like well there's sort of the obvious
thing that you could hope for right
which let's call it
the conjecture by pca
the reason i write quotes around the
conjecture is that if you look at pca he
never comes out and says
i conjecture that this is true but uh
it's very clear you know in the
i'll just say in a moment what pca did
um
what should the version of this on the
discrete cube look like well obviously
we should just replace the gaussians by
discrete
by random size right so it would be
that let epsilon and delta be two
vectors of iid random signs
sine vectors right so
maybe i should just say epsilon and
delta are two independent random points
drawn from the discrete cube
right and then what do we want
then we want for all functions
on the discrete cube
to a norm space x
and all p greater or equal than one we
would like to have the expectation
of f minus the expectation of f norm x
squared and here of course by
expectation i mean that i picked the
the the the the point in the discrete
cube randomly
right is bounded by some constant
times the expectation sum i is one to n
of delta i times df sorry now not df dxi
now we want to discrete derivative
so we want d i f of epsilon
x right that's that's what we would
conjecture and what have i done here
i've literally taken the gaussian result
and i've replaced the two independent
gaussian vectors by two independent
points in the discrete cube and now i
have a discrete cube analog of the
gaussian linear to non-linear prints
let's give this thing
so it would be great if such a thing is
true right because then we have just
completely transferred what we know from
the gaussian cases of sweet cube
and then we can play exactly the same
game right and for example then
of course once you have such an
inequality um
you immediately get end flows the the
end flows problem will immediately be
solved right because you can just apply
the definition of type to the right hand
side your condition on epsilon apply the
definition of type to delta
and inflow's problem is solved right so
it's very clear that this is what we
aspired
right so then all that's left is to
prove it
right so so um pca uh pca worked on this
right and in the same
text where he has this gaussian theorem
he has an analog under this
cube so pca
he proved such an inequality
and the way he proved it is he tried to
somehow mimic the gaussian case right so
you take two independent epsilon and
delta
you try to somehow rotate between them
and do ddt like in the gaussian case but
now of course
there's no rotation in variance so
things go wrong so then you have to work
right and you try to fix what goes wrong
and you know
and he did his best and what he managed
to prove
he proved such a inequality but with a
constant
depending logarithmically on the
dimension n
of the discrete and of course
once the constant is no longer dimension
free
this is no longer a puncher inequality
right the whole point of these puncher
inequalities is that they should be
dimension free
and as soon as this constant starts
growing with dimension it is only
logarithmic so you could say it's not so
bad
right but that is not what we aspire to
right we want the dimension free
inequality
and and the inequality where the
constant growing like log n is not
dimensioned
right so um that's where the matter
stood
and um you know so the hope is that one
can give a better proof
right that will get a dimensional
constant right that is the whole
so
[Music]
now telegram
[Music]
he well telegram shows that if we take
x to be l infinity
then constant being log n
is necessary
and unfortunately so he cooked up a
function
from the discrete cube to l infinity for
every n
um for which
the uh the quantity you wanted right
outside really is log n
smaller than the quantity on the left
hand side and therefore the conjecture
is false
so unfortunately this conjecture looks
great
this conjecture looks great until you
find a counter example
um but it turns out that pca you know
pca proved this with login and that's
actually the best you can do you know
actually this inequality star is not
true
it is simply false um
the way it is because there exists a
bound of space at infinity not a very
esoteric bundle space and a function
that goes to this bond of space for
which you need the login
so this is very strange right you know
at first instance you think that uh um
uh we understand everything the gaussian
case surely the the this case on the
screen cube must be similar right so you
write down what the inequality should be
on the screen cube
and then it turns out actually this cube
works completely differently than the
gaussian case right
something that worked on the on the
gaussian case for any bond of space
right um uh with dimension three
constants suddenly under discrete cube
you
you need to have a growth in the
dimension in order to make this work
um and uh just to go back to a question
somebody asked me in the last lecture
somebody asked me about l infinity what
happens when p
is infinity um so
pca's pcas uh theorem with log n
does also work when p is infinity so
this constant of pca doesn't actually
depend on p
right but uh later we will have
constants
that's not true but yes does
does the login have anything to do with
k connectivity or is that
unrelated absolutely not
no okay um
i don't want to tell you i mean i don't
want to talk about in these lectures but
actually
in a posteriori after we've proved the
result i'm going to describe it will
turn out that for k convex bonus spaces
star does hold over dimension 3 constant
so um yeah so but but but this is a
different uh different matter i i
i yeah as far as i understand the the k
convexity has nothing to do with vlog
okay um
good now we're stuck right because we
have a program
we finally found the right formulation
of the property we want to prove
and then it turned out the property was
just false on the discrete cube right
so now what do we do right now there are
different things you can try to do
um well you can um one of the hopes
that existed for a long time so um
the maybe the big big push in this
direction was given in a 2002 paper of
asafoen
and guidon chechman where
they decided that okay maybe on the
discrete cube this is not true for every
banner space because for l infinity you
need to log in
but maybe for many bun of spaces it
still is true right
so maybe we should assume more about x
not just take
any x like in the gaussian in case maybe
on the discrete cube you just need more
assumptions on x to make it work
um and so where do you find it well what
they try
to do is they try to um
use methods of harmonic analysis because
that's the obvious thing you would want
to try to do on the discrete cube as we
said in the first lecture discrete cube
equals fourier analysis so you start
doing free analysis
and they have very very beautiful clever
proof that this inequality star holds if
you assume that the ban of space
x has a property called umd um and i
don't want to talk a lot about this
this property but this is a restrictive
property it certainly doesn't hold for
every space of type p for example
but this is a very well known property
in harmonic analysis because in harmonic
analysis
it's been known since the 80s through
the work of burkholder
that many theorems and harmonic analysis
hold if and only if you're working in a
banner space that is umd
this is a very fundamental idea in
harmonic analysis even the the
lp bounds on the hilbert transform only
work in umd spaces and this is one of
the most basic results harmonic analysis
so it seems that going this route um
restricts you to these type of
umd biospaces for somehow fundamental
reasons
so um but there have been a line of
follow-up works on this so they never
got very much further than umd biospaces
right so it doesn't really capture what
happens in the general amount of space
like in the gaussian case
um then i want to give a plug to a
different method this method will not
help us
um but um you know let's talk about
methods of proof right so in the
gaussian case
um we use the rotation in variance of
the gaussian distribution
right that was the idea but of course in
the discrete cube you don't have
rotation in variance right so now organ
shackman for example went through
harmonic analysis and tried to do
something else
right but um
there is one idea that i find so
absolutely amazing that i have to tell
you about it
um and that is an idea of francois lu
speaker
and francoise mosby god had the idea
that actually
there is a way of using rotation and
variance
on the discrete cube how can it be right
the discrete cube is obviously not
rotation invariant if i take plus or
minus 1 to the n and i rotate it i don't
have plus or minus 1 to the n
well the idea is to think about rather
than thinking about the elements of this
cube as random bits
right as bits think of them as qubits
okay so go to the quantum world so in
the quantum world you know if you have a
bunch of qubits
right let's say n qubits then you can
take an observable for example sigma x
the spin in the x direction and if you
were to measure that observable you'd
get plus or minus one exactly like a
classical bit right
so you could take a bunch of sigma x
observables
and they would uh behave exactly like
the discrete cube
but you could also take a bunch of sigma
z observable so you could measure the
magnetic field in the z direction and
you'd also get a bunch of qubits
and now her idea is that in the quantum
world
you have rotation in variance what you
should rotate is not plus or minus one
you shouldn't rotate
um the values the outcome of the
measurement but what you should rotate
is your measurement apparatus whether
you're measuring in the z direction or
the x direction
this is like a rotation between two
non-commuting observables you take a
rotation between sigma x and sigma z
i realize that those of you who have
never seen quantum mechanics or quantum
information or something like this have
absolutely no idea what i'm talking
about so i'm just
i'm saying this for those of you who
know something about quantum information
um one can run pca's argument in the
quantum world because in the quantum
world you can in fact rotate between two
non-commuting observables
both of which behave like like random
signs
and uh then you can if once you realize
this amazing fact
you can sit down and you can literally
repeat the the proof of pca's uh
theorem it's much harder but you can
literally try to repeat it
in the scalar case for scalar functions
and it works
and not only does it work but it gives
theorems that that for
uh for for a long time we didn't know
how to prove in any other way they give
bounds on these transform inequalities
and all sorts of punching qualities that
are better than the usual ones
um and um recently we discovered a whole
bunch of completely classical proofs of
these things
but at least one inequality that we
still don't know how to prove it any
other way
so um this is to me a really amazing
thing you know there is a class clinical
completely classical inequalities about
random vectors on the discrete cube that
we
only know how to prove using quantum
using quantum methods
so if you asked me to guess i believe
that all of these things can in fact be
proved classically but uh um
it is really a pretty amazing fact and
you know maybe one of you will once run
into a situation where you remember this
and are like oh maybe that method would
work
so this is due to francoise
all right um let me not say any more
about that so let's go back to what we
actually want to talk about
so um
we are now in a situation we don't know
we want to prove a linear
to non-linear principle on the discrete
cube but it seems like there's some sort
of obstruction because we wrote down
what it should be and it doesn't
actually work because it's dimension
dependent and it has to be that way
right so um now what
right well um what we realized with
um with pata vanisphili and sasha
volberg
is that um you know it looks like
something goes wrong in the discrete
cube here right it looks like for some
reason
the linear to non-linear principle that
worked in the gaussian case
doesn't work on the discrete q um and
what we realize is that that's not
really true
right actually there is a complete
analog
of the uh linear tuning linear principle
in the gaussian case on the discrete
cube
it's just that this equation star which
is sort of the naive transcription of
the theorem of pci to the square cube
is not the correct way to write the
analogous inequality on the discrete
cube
so there is a different inequality in
this q q that looks more complicated
than this one
but that is literally the direct analog
of the
gaussian case on this and once you
understand how to formulate it properly
and why it's true
you can transfer everything from the
gaussian case to the screen tube but you
have to have a
you know you cannot do it naively by
replacing gaussians by random signs
so this is going to become very clear
very quickly so
um i'm just going to rather than giving
you a result i'm just going to
start with proving it right so um
what was the idea in pca the idea in pca
is to do this interpolation method that
we used already to prove the puncher
inequality
right to interpolate between the
function and maybe the function on an
independent copy of the
of of the random vector or maybe the
expectation
right um but unlike in the case of the
variance where we did the interpolation
on the expectation of f squared right we
interpolated between the expectation of
f squared and the expectation of f
squared
in pca's proof we directly interpolate
on the values of the function itself
right we interpolate between the
function
of g and the function of g prime where g
prime is and then the final copy of g
now doing this using rotational
invariance is hopeless on the cube
right um you can't do this right
um well i said you could do it in the
quantum world what i forgot to say
is that this doesn't seem to extend to
vector valued functions because vector
valued functions don't play well with
quantum probability
um there is a theory of operator spaces
which is like a non-community version of
mono space theory but it's much more
restrictive and it doesn't seem to play
very well right so this
this idea of blue speak out is very
beautiful but it seems to give new
inequalities for scalar functions but we
we don't know how to get any vector
value functions from this right
so rotation and variance seems to be out
the window
so let's go back to what we know which
is the semi group right
i mean let's just go back to the semi
group that's that's and the semi group
beautifully interpolates between the
functions expectation right because
if i take a function of the discrete
cube minus the expectation of the
function
well that's just p zero of if minus p
infinity of if right
and now i can interpolate as usual but
now you see i'm not interpolating on the
expectation
of the function i'm interpolating
directly on the values of the function
but why not i can write this as minus
the integral from zero to infinity
of ddt of ptf
all right and what was ddt of ptf well
it's the laplacian
right so this let's write it as the
integral from 0 to infinity
sum i is 1 to n of d i
of ptf
dt
so
i want to clarify that what i've done so
far is even more naive than what pca did
right i mean using the rotational
variance that's actually an idea
right but using the semi group to
interpolate between f and its
expectation i mean that's even simpler
than the proof of the puncher inequality
right but what's the problem i mean in
in pca's proof using rotational
invariance
when we took d dt of this g of theta or
dd theta of this g of theta
this g prime popped up remember so when
we differentiated
um with respect to to the angle the
interpolation
that's where this linear function came
from that shows up on the right hand
side of psa's inequality
but if you look here in this equation
over here where is the linear function
going to come from we have only one
epsilon right remember i want to have
something like a delta i want to have
some other random variables delta right
that are going to be linear combinations
that show up right
but i where are they going to come from
i mean it's not clear where they're
going to come from there is no deltas
there's just an epsilon
right so um that's the problem
right i mean how how are we ever going
to come up with this linear function
that shows up on the right hand side and
is going to give us um
give us the linear linear principle
right
um so this is really you know
the every joke has a punch line right so
i'm now ready for the punch line
um what's the punch line
we get it let me write the lemma
the punch line punch
now it will be a formula but once i
prove the formula it will be very clear
why it's true
okay so what is the punch line let me
introduce some delta
let's define delta i of t
it's psi i of t remember what is psi i
of t this is this
random variable that showed up inside
the probabilistic representation of the
semi group
right it was plus 1 with probability 1
plus e to the minus t over 2 and minus 1
with probability minus e to the 1 minus
e to the minus t over 2.
and i'm just going to standardize it so
i'm going to subtract its mean
and i'm going to divide it by the square
root of its standard dev of its variance
so it's standard deviation
and now now that i've standardized it's
become a random variable of mean 0 and
variance 1.
because i've subtracted the mean and
i've divided by the square root of the
variance so now it has mean 0 and
variance 1.
and these expectation variance you can
just compute them right this is psi i of
t minus e to the minus t
divided by square root of 1 minus e to
the minus 2t
okay so there it is this is the
definition right so i just defined it
like this
so this is like a delta i this there
anova is going to play the role of my
delta i right the delta i is the random
sign that was going to be the linear
combination and like a random sign it
has mean zero and variance one
but it's no longer has the same
probability of being positive or
negative it's like a biased version of a
random sign
okay it's a biased version of a random
sign of mean zero and variance one
and then we have the following formula
if i differentiate the heat
the heat semi group
i can write this this is an identity e
to the minus t
divided by square root 1 minus e to the
minus 2t
of the expectation of respect to c of
delta i of t
times d i f epsilon x
and now you see if you look in this
expression i have at the top of the page
where inside the integral i have the sum
i is 1 to n of d i p t f
if i sum this expression i is 1 to n i'm
going to get exactly a linear function
of the derivatives
with these delta i's serving as the
coefficients
right and that's exactly what's going to
give us our linear to nonlinear prints
so let me um let me prove this
and now you will see that all of this
pedantic computation that we did at the
beginning of the second lecture is going
to pay off because this
computation is very simple let's go back
we have a formula for ptf of epsilon
let me yeah okay we have a formula for
ptf of epsilon
what is it we can sum
[Music]
over psi in plus minus 1 to the n
right and then we have this product j is
1 to n
1 plus epsilon j x i j e to the minus t
over 2 times f sine
so let's compute what happens if we take
d
i of ptf
so what do we do we just flip the sine
of epsilon
i right of the ith bit subtract that and
divide by two
so all that's going to happen is that
the one in the one plus
epsilon i x c i e times t over two is
going to disappear right when i take the
derivative
so let me write it like this
i'm still going to keep my whole product
like this but now what i have to do is
the i term of this product i have to
remove the one
so in for the for to do that i'm just
going to divide by the i term
and i'm going to multiply by the thing
where i've removed the one
right so by multiplying by this quantity
that i wrote over here
um uh i've just removed the one from the
ice term
right right so
if you just reverse this through the
definition of
uh um of of the random variable ct this
is the expectation
c of f
epsilon c t times
then we get c i t e to the minus t
divided by one plus c i t
e to the minus t
this this was just we just computed it
and what is this quantity over here
right well if i just multiply it by one
minus
c i t e to the minus t on top and bottom
right let's call this
a if i multiply a by 1 minus
c i t e to the minus t on top and bottom
on the bottom i get 1 minus e to the
minus 2t
and on the top i get c i t
e to the minus t times 1 minus
c i t e to the minus t
right and if you multiply this out this
e to the minus t is going to go out
front
c i t times 1 minus here t e to the
minus c is just c i t minus e to the
minus t so that comes over here
right and i get divided by 1 minus e to
the minus 2 t
which i've split into the product of the
square roots right one square root goes
here and one square root goes here in
the definition of delta h
right so
what i have done is i have proved this
this lemma x with one difference i have
proved that this lemma is true but but
without even this ti over here i've just
proved that this lemma is true with f
right without the ti
but that's not a problem because you see
um
seem to have frozen
um that's another problem why isn't it a
problem
well notice that d i p t f
is d i squared p t f because d i is
equal to d i squared remember
and d i commutes with p t so this is
also equal to d
i of p t d i f
right so it doesn't matter if i want d
i p t f i can just add a d i over here
inside and then i get exactly this
formula over here
that's the end of the
so it looks like a little bit of a silly
computation right so let me give you an
interpretation of what just happened
here
okay so so um because
this this lemma that i've just proved
here is is is a very basic lemma that i
think
every one of you has seen it in another
context it just for some reason on the
discrete cube people don't think about
it this way
i mean probably it exists somewhere but
but uh
um we at least did not realize the
importance of this i mean we proved this
like
three years ago four years ago at msri
just as a lemma in something else so we
didn't realize the importance of it
until until more recently okay so
um it just seemed like an obvious lemma
what actually happened here
let's let's um think about uh
what this semi-group is doing right so
this semi-group ptf what is this formula
that i wrote over here
what i've said here is that i'm
convolving the function f
with this heat kernel with this product
over here is the heat kernel right
so i'm just convolving a function with
some with a heat kernel
right now you know in many other
situations for example suppose i have a
function on rn
right now suppose i convolve it with a
gaussian
all right so what is this this is the
integral of e to the minus
y minus x squared over two times
f of y d y right this is the with some
normalization right so this is the
convolution of a function f with a gauss
what does that convolution do right i
might start with a very non-smooth
function
f for example something like this right
but after i convolve it with a gaussian
it'll look smoother right
this is f convolved with a gaussian
maybe i should add an epsilon so after
i've convolved the function with a
smooth function with a gaussian it looks
smoother
right what does it mean it means that
this convolved function should have more
derivatives than the original function
right because it's much smoother than
the original function
how do you see this in the formula well
if i compute d dx of this
well i have two options either i can put
the d dx over here
on the f and this is the analog of the
statement that d i commutes with pt
right but another thing that i could do
is i could instead compute ddx of the
gaussian kernel
right and if i do that then i exactly
get
a y from y minus x popping out front
inside this excitation right so if i
differentiate the convolution of a
function of the gaussian
i get the integral of y times the
gaussian kernel times f of y right
and there you see that actually that's
where the smoothing comes in because i
have a derivative on the left hand side
but on the right hand side i don't have
a derivative of f i just got a y
a linear function sitting in here right
so this shows you why i mean the fact
that you can differentiate
the kernel the smooth kernel rather than
the function shows you why
um the derivative of a convolution the
convolution is more derivatives is
smoother than the original function
and we did exactly the same thing here
in this limit on the discrete cube
so you should really think of this lemma
as a smoothing estimate
right it's showing exactly this
phenomenon over here that you can take a
function which is very non-smooth and it
becomes smooth when you convolve it with
some sort of
smooth function it's not so clear what a
smooth function is
but in this case what smooth function is
is that if we take this function over
here and we differentiate it we just pop
out the linear function of delta i t in
front
right so this is just an immediate
analog of this property over
here of convolutions which uh probably
anybody who's ever done some calculus
computations has at some point in their
lives
understood why convolving like this with
a smooth function smooths the function
so this is the intuition but once we
have it
then we're basically almost done because
we're just going to take this lemma so
let me go to the next page so
what i'm going to do let me just point
it out i'm just going to take
you see here i have an equation for d i
p t f epsilon
here i have d i p t f epsilon i'm going
to take this expression i'm going to
plug it in there
and that's what i'm going to write on
the next page okay so i don't need to
prove it i just literally
substitute that into that formula and
then we call it theorem
okay so what is the theorem
so this is with pata and
sasha um the theorem says
ah maybe i will prove it let me start
with the proof and then i'll show you
the theorem
right so what i just said is that if i
take f
epsilon minus the expectation of f it's
equal to the integral from 0 to infinity
1
sorry e to the minus t over square root
1 minus e to the minus 2 t
of the expectation with respect to psi
of delta i t
times f of epsilon psi t
and i want to think of this as the
analog of the interpolation that pca got
by doing rotation and variance
now what happens if i want to get an
inequality for the expectation
of the norm of f minus the expectation
of f
square to the p well i just
apply it on both sides of these
inequalities right and i try to bring
the norm inside the integral
right now for the norm to go inside the
integral remember in pca i had to divide
by pi over 2
to make the integral have mass 1.
so i'm going to do that here too we're
going to think of this as the density of
a measure so let's define
the measure mu dt on the positive
real line to be 2 over pi
times e to the minus t
times e to the minus t
i'm going too far up so i'm defining now
a measure on the real on the positive
real line e to the minus t
over square root minus e to the minus
two t d t
right this defines a measure on real
line and i've normalized it that it's so
that it's a probability
measure
the anti-derivative of this function e
to the minus t over square root this is
like an arc sign so if you normalize it
you have to do two over pi
and so if you normalize it like this
then this integral becomes a probability
measure and i can just use jensen just
like in pca proof to move this norm to
the p
inside and what do we get we get
pi over 2 to the p which coincidentally
is exactly the same
constant as in pca's gaussian inequality
times the integral
let me maybe do it like this
so it's the same pi over 2 as npca the
constant is identical times the integral
of the expectation
sum i is 1 to n delta i t
times d i f
of epsilon x
to the p to the 1 over p mu dt
so remember this mu dt is a probability
measure
on the positive real line and
here is our linear to non-linear
principle
so remember what was the conjecture ah
maybe i should emphasize
where did the epsilon times ct go to
where did the ct go to
well remember when we take the
expectation when we move it inside now
we take the expectation over epsilon
and epsilon is uniformly distributed
under the street cube
right so if i multiply that by any signs
the distribution doesn't change we've
already used this when we showed
probabilistically that the expectation
of ptf equals the expectation of if
that was show the stationary property
right so once we take the expectation of
respect to epsilon we can condition on
the ct
take first the expectation with respect
to epsilon this uniform distribution on
this cube is an invariant by changing
the signs and the ct just disappears
and we get here beautifully the norm of
a linear function of the derivatives of
the function f
the derivative of function f have
epsilons in them right
but the coefficients of the linear
combination
they are not delta i's if these were
delta i's they were independent random
signs
then we would get that conjecture of pca
on the previous slide
conjecture star right but we know it's
false
right because telegram proved the
counter example right
so what we've done is instead of putting
here unbiased random signs in the linear
combination
we turn the random signs in the linear
combination
into biased random signs
and then we have some sort of average
over the bias parameter t
right with respect to some probability
measure mu
and the point is that even though
remember this is an inequality an
unbiased inequality is an inequality for
a function on the discrete cube where we
picked every sign to be unif iid plus or
minus one of probability one half
right so it's an inequality for the
unbiased q
but even though it's an inequality for
the unbiased cube
the correct analog of the gaussian
inequality
relates the poncarena quality on the
unbiased tube
with the behavior of linear functions on
the bottom of space but in the linear
functions we have to allow ourselves to
consider
biased biased uh
random random signs and that's the
crucial point
that makes it work and for example
telegram's counter example disappears
when you do this tell the grounds
counter example somehow came from the
fact that
that you take here unbiased delta eyes
so this is an this is
our linear to non-linear principle
on the discrete group and i would argue
this is the correct linear to non-linear
principle on the cube
so fonquerain equality
for non-linear
functions on the discrete cube and now i
mean
on the discrete cube with the uniform
distribution of this cube
is controlled by the behavior
of linear functions
but with biased
variables so if i understand how linear
for how the expectation of the norm of a
linear function behaves on a given norm
space
but not just for unbiased variables but
also for biased variables
then i will get a poincare inequality
for vector-valued functions on that
space
which matches exactly the behavior of
the linear functions
okay and it's just it's a you know
the key insight here is i mean the proof
you saw it it was easy it was not
you know uh we used nothing really i
mean it was easier than the proof of the
punk rain equality at least if you did
it the way i did it
right um the key idea here is to realize
what is the correct formulation of this
of this linear to non-linear principle
and once you have it you know there's
this one very simple lemma that i'm sure
many people have written down without
thinking about what its significance is
um and um
and out pops the correct principle
now um i don't i want to move on to the
next topic so i don't want to um
um i don't want to for example formally
derive from this
the end flow the solution of the info
problem i just want to say very briefly
of course the point here you know if you
have the definition of type p
it's in terms of unbiased delta eyes
right
and here we need to have a sort of form
of type for unbiased
but that is a you know that aspect of it
can be handled using classical tricks
there's a there's a technique called
symmetrization which um
you can find in uh i mean you learn this
uh when you start working with high
dimensional spaces
it's it's it's a standard trick that
allows you to go from
linear functions of biased random
variables to linear functions of
unbiased random variables
so going from here for example to the
application of proving the m flow
conjecture
is really a routine thing it requires a
couple of lines um
but because i want to move on to a
different topic it's sort of not has
nothing to do with the discrete cube
okay this is just a
it's a standard trick and you can ask me
about it if you want to know about it
but um
yes yes yeah i daniel yes
yeah just to be clear so the delta i's
are not even signs right they're
supported on two points
but as as t goes to zero
they can uh they can take arbitrarily
large values right
exactly so what you do is you start with
a biased random sign
really a sign plus or minus one but with
different probabilities
right that's cit but that
if you buy if you take a random sign but
you make it biased of course it doesn't
have mean zero
right so this delta it's you start with
a biased random sign but then you
standardize
it to have mean zero and variance one
but as the bias becomes worse and worse
of course to standardize it you have to
scale it by a larger and larger factor
so as t goes to zero the variance is one
but the moments above two blow up as t
goes to zero and that's exactly what
kills the counter example of telegraph
because the counter example of telegram
used the fact that the
that the delta eyes were bounded random
variables and the fact that these delta
it's
actually blow up as t goes to zero that
you have a singularity there that's
exactly what causes the
total ground counter example to
disappear and can you recover the
gaussian inequality from this
yes the central limit theorem you can
use the central limit theorem uh it's a
simple exercise
um by the central limit theorem you you
take this you plug in the central limit
theorem the gaussian equality pops up
with the sharp cost
so the gaussian equal is actually
special case of this inequality on the
discrete
are there more questions uh there are
several more questions if you want to
take a break to answer them
um i can i can read them so the first
question is is the pci connection true
or known for x equals r
um ah yeah okay so so um
well for x equals r it follows from this
uh uh
so there are many things that we can
understand after this so the pta
conjecture
you're asking whether star with unbiased
rather markers whether that inequality
holds for certain bundle spaces
right this is the original askers okay
so one can now go back and ask and
answer all sorts of questions that were
not obvious before once one has the
right principle
so remember originally we had this
inequality star with unbiased by the
markers
it doesn't hold for l infinity for
example so you can ask for what boundary
space is x does this inequality hold
with a dimension free constant that's a
reasonable question
right and once we know this once we know
the right inequality
we can go back and answer that question
and it turns out it's true if and only
if
x is finite code type and that also
answers the question that daniel asked
me before so it has doesn't have to do
with k convexity
because k convexity is equivalent to
having finite type or non-trivial type
but actually the correct condition for a
star to hold with dementia free console
this happens if and only if the banner
space has um
has finite code type and by a classical
theorem of
mpca that means that l infinity is
really the only obstruction
a bundle space has non-trivial code type
if and only if
uh it doesn't contain any copies of l
infinity as subspaces
so this l infinity example of telegram
turns out to be the only obstruction to
the validity of this star with uh um
with dimension free constant but i don't
know how to prove this without proving
the more general theorem that holds in
any bonus space right this is a
consequence of the theorem over here
so r the real line of course does have
fun it has
called type 2 and type 2 and everything
is nice
cool um so another question i think was
related to this constant login and the
thing that pc approved
yes and they asked is it related to the
fact that gaussian width and radar
marker which
width differ by that factor no okay
they differ by square root log okay
all right so ahmad asked uh if there's
an understanding of the optimal
constants
the constant to me like it is the pi
over yes pi over two is optimal and i
gave the example at the end of the last
lecture
or the in the questions at the end of
the last lesson and then the last one is
more of a comment i guess in a question
amir denver points out that higher
moments will behave badly
due to the recentering of the bias
bernoullis very good so
higher ones if you go so for for the
question of type for the info problem it
doesn't matter because you uh
type can only be between one and two so
it's moments higher than two
so what happens if you have moments
higher than two is that the the delta
it's have the moments start blowing up
but they will blow up slower than one
over square root t for any finite p
and you see that this measure mu dt as a
one over square root t singularity at t
equals zero
so the integral will actually be finite
for every finite p
if you plug in p is infinity it will
blow up but for any finite p the
integral will actually be finite
um but there is a very you know so this
is just a starting point you can ask
many questions after this and and a lot
of this is ongoing work
um one of the questions you can ask for
example if you can deduce
uh concentration of measure on the
discrete cube which we know how to prove
using luxol of inequality
can you deduce it from this and you can
try and
um i'm not talking about scalar
functions and what you realize is that
because of this blow up property over
here
the moments will start growing like p
not like square root p so they will look
like it's sub-exponential concentration
even though we know subgaussian
concentration is true
um and we understand now what is
why that is and we have better estimates
that explain why this is
at one point here we did jensen right
because what did i do
in the proof right if i take the
expectation the norm i get this
expectation over c
here i get it inside and i just got rid
of it in jensen
and you lose a little bit there and and
if you do uh more work then you can
get a better estimate that doesn't have
this inefficiency and
this can give you better dependence of
the constants on p
um and um i would like to point out that
that that actually proves an inequality
that was previously only known to hold
because of lucika's non-computative
results so that gives commutative proofs
of these types of inequalities
um but this really takes me far afield
but uh but there are many very
interesting questions and also open
questions related to this that
i don't have time to describe if i want
to cover some other topics as well
but this is a very good point the the
moments larger than two blow up
of the of the delta i t's but they blow
up slower than one over square root
t which is the singularity in the
measure that's not an obvious fact you
need to compute
any more questions
all right so what i promised to do so i
could you know i could have probably
spent the rest of my lectures on this
but
but what i want to do now is i want to
switch gears because i promised to show
you two results one result was uh this
vector value theory
and now i wanted to show you a very
different result which is uh the recent
result of uh
ronnie and renan kos on boolean
functions so now we're going to go to
the completely opposite direction
um up to now we've been talking about
functions of the discrete cube which
take values
in a bonus space right vector valued
functions now i want to go to the
completely the opposite direction
and talk about functions in the discrete
cube that take only two values
right which is basically the opposite
right
so boolean functions
and for um simplicity
um just because of notational
convenience i'm going to define a
boolean function to be a function of
this q cubed not to minus 1 1 but to 0
okay so of course this is the same up to
a factor 2 minus 1 or something like
this right so
that makes absolutely no difference i
mean the statement of the results are
all going to be identical but
it's just a little bit algebra you know
for algebra purposes this is actually
just slightly easier so i'm going
to use that as my convention of a
boolean
so um let's talk about boolean functions
so
um well a boolean function of course is
just a function
right you can just view it as a special
case of a real valued function which is
a special case of a vector-valued
function
right so to boolean functions you can
apply all of the
um uh you know techniques that we've
been discussing right
um so for example you can apply the
punch inequality to boolean functions
right why not well nothing is stopping
you but it turns out that the poncarena
quality actually tends to give pretty
bad results when you apply to boolean
functions
um and if you want to have a very sort
of hand wavy reason why
that might be expected um you know
remember that for the poncare inequality
it gave optimal results it was sharp
when the function is linear
right for linear functions the poincare
inequality is sharp um
but no boolean function looked like a
linear function right i mean so
maybe you would expect that for boolean
functions you can do better than the
punch
inequality because you know they're sort
of very far away from linear functions
that's not a real explanation that's
just a first hint about what's going on
so let me give you the simplest example
um which is the majority function so
let's take the function f of epsilon
so it's going to be one if at least half
of the bits are
are one right so if some i is one to
n epsilon i is let's say greater than n
over two
so this is called the majority function
this is how elections are conducted in
an actual democracy
right you know we have n voters they
each vote for democrat or republican
if more than half of the people vote for
democrat and the democrat wins and if
more than half the people vote for
republican republican wins
right that's the that is the um
that is the majority function now let's
look what happens so so the majority
function
[Music]
because each of the bits is equal to
likely to be positive or negative the
more majority function has
this the this has expectation one-half
right
the probability that the majority is one
is the same as the probability the
majority is that minus so it's one
right so um uh in particular the
the the variance of this function f
right so this is the expectation of f
squared minus the expectation of f
squared
but you know for boolean function f
squared and f are the same right so this
is one half
minus one quarter which is one quarter
okay so the variance is of order one
chord
now let's look at the right hand side of
the punch inequality so this is
um let me write it pedantically
so this is a sum i is 1 to n
of the expectation t i f squared right
so what is dif right so what i do is i
flip the ith bit
and i look if the outcome changes right
so this is one when is this one that's
one if the voter i
changes his mind then the outcome of the
election changes right
let's say you know the outcome the
election as this right now is is
is democrat right but one voter voter i
decides to switch their vote from
democrat republican and suddenly the
whole outcome of the election changes to
republican
right then d i of f is equal to one and
otherwise d i of f is equal to zero
so d i of f is an indicator function
that the voter i can change the outcome
of the election by switching their vote
so what so the expectation of that of
course is the probability
that voter i will change the outcome of
the election if they change their vote
so what is this so first of all this can
obviously only happen when they're
exactly
n over two votes for democrats and n
over two votes for republican
right if there's n over two minus one
votes for democrats then one voter
change their mind won't change the
outcome of the election
right so this can only happen this this
dif can only be non-zero
if there is exactly half of the votes
for the democrats and half of the votes
for the republican
right and in that case if
it is really half half then exactly half
the voters can change the outcome of the
election if they change their mind
right so
you see for um
let me even it's easier to think about
this if i move the sum inside
so this expectation right the random
variable inside is zero
if not half the voters change their mind
so it's only non-zero
if exactly half the voters vote for
democrat
what's the probability of that is one
over two to the n times n choose n over
2.
more or less right because i have to
have x
so 1 over 2 to the n is the is the
probability of one outcome because there
are two to the n
uh outcomes in the discrete cube and i
have to have
n over entries n over two is exactly the
number of ways in which exactly n over
two of the voters can vote for them
right and on this event where this
happens
exactly half the voters can change their
mind right so i have this times
n over two because on this event where
exactly half the people vote democrat
the number of voters this would become
the number of voters who change their
mind will change the election it's
exactly half the voters right that's
exactly those that vote just under this
version
so what is this well this quantity over
here now you have to have sterling
approximation okay so you just check it
this is of order 1 over square root n by
sterling formula
um so
this is of order what it's of order n
over square root n of order square root
n
and you see that the poincare inequality
is vastly far
off from the correct answer right
because the right hand side of the
poincare inequality the variance of f
was one quarter
sorry the left-hand side is one-quarter
but the right-hand side of the puncher
inequality is of order square root
right so grows very rapidly with the
number of voters
right so you see here that that's the
punch inequality is
is is very bad in the example of the
majority function
so um so
what one would like to understand in the
case of boolean functions nothing is
wrong with the inequality for general
functions but the inequalities for
general functions the ones we've written
down so far
um they they don't tend to give very
good answers or give very good results
when you apply them to boolean functions
and we would like to understand you know
how you know what what
what is wrong with these inequalities
whether one can prove better
inequalities and
and and how that will help okay so
um before i tell you i'm going to tell
you about
two very different reasons why the
puncher inequality doesn't give good
answers on boolean functions
okay um but before i do that let me just
make a remark
uh what is so special about a boolean
function
well i mean it's just a function that
takes some real values you know why do
you care
that it's just zero or one i mean is
there what is the magic right
actually i mean okay i'm hardly an
expert on boolean functions but but as
far as i can tell the magic is very
limited
boolean functions have the very nice
property that f is equal to f
squared okay
and what this means for example is that
the expectation of
f is also equal to the expectation of f
squared
which means that the the mean is of the
same order as the
as the variance now usually okay
you see for for for linear functions we
typically expect that the
that's the mean will be of order the
standard deviation or the mean the
expectation of the absolute value will
be the same order as the standard
deviation out of the variance
right so there's a square right so for
example if if the probability of the
event is small if it's not one half
this will imply that the expectation of
f
is much much smaller in many cases than
square root of the expectation of f
squared
which is not a property that we expect
for nice functions like linear functions
right but it is a property that we
expect for um
boolean functions at least when the
boolean functions don't have when
they're biased when they don't have
a probability close to one-half let me
give you another such formula which will
come back many many times
right so what is the variance of a
boolean function
we just computed it over here right this
is really the expectation of f
times 1 minus the expectation of f right
because this is really the expectation
of f
squared minus the expectation of f
squared
but f squared is if right so
it's this quantity but what is
the expectation of the absolute value of
f minus the expectation of f so remember
what is the variance
the variance is really the expectation
of
f minus the expectation of f squared
right
but what is just the expected absolute
deviation of the function from itself
well if f is one then this is one minus
the expectation of if
and if f is zero this is just the
expectation of f right so it's the
probability that f is one
which is just the expectation of f times
one minus expectation of f
plus the expectation of f of zero which
is one minus expectation of f times the
estimation of f so this is just two
times the expectation of f times one
minus the expectation of f
which is exactly twice the variance
so again usually you know if you have
sort of functions that behave smoothly
nice functions
you'd expect that the expectation of the
square right the variance to be of order
the square
of the expected absolute deviation but
for boolean function that's not true the
expectation of the square will be the
same order the expectation of the
of the function itself and and this is
what makes boolean functions very
different
so let me um let me immediately show you
one way in which we can exploit this
so i'm going to give you two different
reasons
two distinct reasons
why the punker inequality
is bad for boolean functions
so the first one is that the poincare
inequality is a statement about the
expectation of the square right it says
that the expectation of the square
of f minus expectation of f that's the
variance is bounded by the expectation
of the square
of the gradient of the function but why
should you put a square there
right maybe we need an l1 version
maybe we need to remove this square
because for boolean functions unlike for
linear functions squaring makes a huge
difference
right
so let me let me prove such a thing for
you
for this is not the same a boolean
function this is same about any function
of discrete cube
right
this is like a poncare inequality if i
put a square over here and a square over
here that would be the poincare
inequality
right but why should i put squares there
right i could have this inequality over
here with any power p
right if i wanted well i could ask
whether it's true so here i have an l1
version of the poincare inequality
and such a version holds for any
function right but for example for
linear functions this doesn't give you
any information that you cannot get from
the punch inequality
but for boolean functions i claim that
this inequality is much better exactly
for the reason that we saw in the
previous slide
which is that for a boolean function the
expectation of f squared is very
is or sorry the expectation of f squared
versus f makes a big difference
right let me first prove dilemma
proof okay
by our linear to non-linear principle we
can apply it to the real line
with p equals one
so we get that this is bounded by pi
over two times the integral
of the expectation sum i is one to n
delta i t d i f epsilon
um mu dt
right i just applied the previous
theorem right that that we proved the
linear to the linear principle on the
real line
right x is the real line p equals one
and now what you can do with this
expectation you see the expectation
respect to two things epsilon and delta
so just freeze epsilon just look at the
linear this thing is a linear function
right and just do cauchy schwartz on the
deltas
right so the x if i freeze epsilon i
just take the expectation of the square
of this that will just
become the sum of the squares of dif
epsilon right
so if i just do kosher schwartz on the
eps fonts this is bounded
by the integral of the expectation of df
of epsilon
right this is the expectation with
respect to epsilon m delta but if i just
do kosher schwartz for the expectation
on the delta
mu dt right but mu is a probability
measure and this guy doesn't depend on t
so there it is so this is an immediate
consequence even though we're now in the
in the world of x is the real line and
no longer vector valued function we
still effortlessly let's get
effortlessly get an inequality that
actually took a long time to prove you
know this inequality was first proved by
telegram in the in the early 90s
um and it it wasn't considered to be an
obvious inequality at the time
and with a much with a different
constant i don't know what constant he
got
it's not stated in this paper and it's
probably very large
this concept over here it was was
obtained first by lust picard using her
non-commutative method
and it follows trivially from our um
from our linear to non-linear principle
and actually if i can state the question
we don't know what the
optimal constant is in this inequality
in the discrete cube
in the gaussian case in the last at the
end of the last lecture i mentioned that
the optimal constant is square root pi
over 2.
and it is very natural to conjecture
that this inequality should hold in the
discrete cube also with constant square
root pi over 2.
we have no idea how to prove it but we
do know this constant is not optimal
because if you do
slightly better here if you don't use
koshi schwartz and this inequality you
can actually get a smaller constant
but not an optimal one so it's an
interesting question but it's not going
to be relevant for what i'm going to say
so let's just check the majority
function on this example and then i'll
i'll continue next time
so let's go back yes yeah so sorry when
you do
koshi schwartz don't you you get a a
sum of the delta i squares right that's
right
but uh so why don't you get like n
when you take the so let's let's just do
it so
we get the expectation with respect to
delta some i
is one to n so i'm now taking the
expectation with respect to epsilon
outside
right yeah
right so just upper bound this by that
right that's kosher schwartz
that's what i mean by koshi schwartz you
can just call it jensen
and now you see the cross terms
disappear by independence and so you
only get the diagonal terms so you get
the expectation some is 1 to n of the
expectation of delta i squared
d i f epsilon squared and delta i has
variance 1.
i just get the square root of the sum of
d i f epsilon squared and that's
and and i get the expectation respect to
epson still outside so that's that's
what i wrote
is it good yeah okay let me very quickly
because i think i'm already slightly
over time
let's quickly check the majority
function and then we'll continue next
time with the second reason why the
punker inequality is bad
so let's go back to f of epsilon as the
majority function
right so remember what is the
expectation of
f minus the expectation of f well
remember we computed this is just two
times the variance of f
so that's one half that's two times one
quarter
so that doesn't change right so the this
is the same as we have it for the
variance up to a factor 2.
but now we have the expectation of the
gradient of f remember in the punch
inequality there was a square here
but now we're removing that square
so what is this well remember that
df is zero unless exactly half of the
voters vote democrat
so the probability that that happens is
two to the minus n n choose n over two
right but when that happened exactly
half of the voters
can flip the outcome of the election
right but this is the square root of the
sum of the squares of those d i's so i
get square root n over 2
rather than n over 2. and this thing was
of order 1 over square root n so this is
of order 1.
and you see i'm not claiming the
constant is optimal but you see that for
for the majority function the poncarene
inequality gives a vastly wrong answer
but
this l1 version of puncher inequality
gives the right answer
the right order of magnitude and it's
simply a matter that because boolean
functions the f
squared is equal to f it makes a
difference what power you take
right and so you should you should work
with the l1 version rather than the o2
version if you want to capture this
phenomenon
and it really is that simple okay but
this is not the only reason why boolean
by the
quran equality gives bad example bad
answers for boolean functions there's a
completely different reason i'm going to
explain it in the next lecture so let me
end here for today thanks
thanks very much there were a couple
questions that
came up so uh maybe i'll ask the one
that came later
because it's about this page so uh clemo
asks uh what else
other than kosher charts can you use to
improve the constant
uh yeah so so you see
let me remind you what happens in the
gaussian case right so in the gaussian
case we get exactly the same thing from
pca statement but we get some i is 1 to
n
gi prime times df dxi
gi right so why did we do better here
right the reason we did better here is
because okay we freeze x i so just think
of
gi being frozen right we condition on gi
so this is a linear combination of
gaussians right so it's just a gaussian
right so this is
gaussian with mean zero and variance
gradient f squared
right gradient f of g squared right
that's this random variable that's
inside this expectation
right the random variable that's inside
this expectation is just gaussian with
mean zero and the variance is the
gradient f of g
squared right but for a gaussian
for a standard gaussian the expectation
of the right so the expectation of a
normal zero sigma squared
squared is just sigma squared that's the
variance but the expectation of the
absolute value of a normal zero sigma
squared
is sigma times square root two over pi
right and this thing is smaller than one
and that's the reason why in the
gaussian case you didn't get pi over two
in the final answer but square root of
pi over 2 because this square root of 2
over pi that comes from the l1 norm of
the gaussian
distribution cancelled out now the
problem is that if you had
rather markers right for let's say you
had unbiased signs the delta i's were
unbiased signs
such as square root two over pi cannot
be true in general right for example
what would happen if all of these
numbers were zero except for the first
one
right then this would just be one
radamaker
in one radar macro the expectation the
absolute value is one it's not square
root two over pi it's not less than one
right so the uh what what one says is
that the optimal constant
in the in the upper kitchen inequality
for p is less than two is one it's not
square root two over pi like in the
gaussian case
but that's only true in the unbiased
case it turns out that if you have
biased if you have biased radamacker
you get a smaller constant in the upper
kitchen inequality for p is less than
two
and um i uh uh i have never seen
anybody write this actually but um but
it's it's a simple x
i don't i have no idea what the optimal
constant is a simple exercise to
convince yourself that the constant is
indeed smaller than one
and that constant trans uh translates to
having a smaller consonant pi over two
in this in quote
so yeah it is because for biased
radamakers
uh the the upper kinshin inequality for
p is smaller than two is actually better
than for
for unbiased which is exactly the
opposite of the way you usually think
about it
but that's because you usually think
about p being greater than two so it's
not a surprise
i hope that answered the question
uh there's a question from nick cook
nick you can amuse yourself
yeah hi ramon hi nick so uh
maybe you i realize i i came in a bit
late so maybe you
addressed this earlier but um uh in your
formula
you with the interpolation you had this
measure mu on the positive
real line uh which i mean it seemed to
suggest that we could have i mean i
think this is just the push forward of
the uniform measure on zero two pi
so so could we have just parameterized
everything
it's the first forward of the arc sign
laws here on the on the on the unit
um okay well
either way could could i mean it it
seems to suggest we could have
parameterized everything as a rotation
all along sure um so i was wondering if
that could ever if that's a very
useful perspective not as far as i can
tell
um i mean
it's just a change of variables right
sure
but the distributions of the object
we're working with are not rotationally
invariant
you know so just because you take a
function and you parametrize it by an
angle doesn't mean that you have
rotational invariance right
yeah i mean it's this time parameter
where we're we're
we're changing not the right yeah sure
the message you're just you're just
you're just basically
rescaling it right so you know i can
take any
you know i can take any function the
positive real line and rescale it so
that becomes a function from zero to pi
or from zero to two pi
but it doesn't mean that i've got that
i've accomplished anything right
i i guess i don't you know i don't see
why just reparameterizing the function
is going to help you
okay right i mean the key point i want
to make an uh maybe i should make a
point about pca's proof pcs proproses
rotational invariance right
and why npcs proof doesn't he have this
mu dt
right because actually in pc based proof
he did have an integral there was an
integral from zero to pi over two
of some quantity which depended on theta
right
but it turned out that the distribution
of um
the distribution of what was inside the
integral didn't depend on theta and
that's why the integral disappeared
right and what we're saying here is that
on the discrete cube that's not true the
distribution does depend on theta
or on t whatever you want to call it and
so you have to keep it because the
distribution depends on on t right
but if you think about it that way this
is very misleading because then you
would say like well what but then in
that case
you know why couldn't we just directly
apply pca why do we need rotation in
variance why couldn't we just directly
apply
pca strict we take two rather markers we
rotate them okay
maybe they're not rather markers anymore
but they have some other distribution
right and we just keep that inside the
integral right
so um but that's not the important thing
about the rotational variance in pga's
case
the important thing about rotational
advance in pca's case where it's used
crucially is not
to show that the distribution of let's
say
g i prime theta is invariant under theta
where it's used crucially is to ensure
that this part and that
part are independent because you see if
epsilon and delta i t were dependent
right or if we go back to the beginning
um if this gi prime and this g were
dependent
then you could not condition on g and
apply uh
uh statements about linear functions on
bonus spaces
right and the crucial part of rotational
invariance in pca's proof is that it
ensures that this g
prime and g of theta remain independent
of each other of every theta
it so happens that they also keep the
same distribution which is why at the
end of the day the integral disappears
from the final results
but that wasn't the important part about
the rotational invariance the
important part about the rotational
invariance is that it preserves
independence
and if i were to rotate between two
radar independent if i were to take two
independent rather markers
and rotate them then the two coordinate
directions would no longer be
independent and that's really the reason
why
uh rotational invariance is really
absolutely doesn't work yeah
sure and and and so um um
of course you can parametrize t any way
you want you know you can take any
increasing function of t and
reparameterize this integral but that in
itself is not going to help you the
question is
what probabilistic phenomenon are you
trying to to exploit here
and i i don't see why just changing
variables is going to help
yeah yeah i was just wondering if it
might have an interpretation
the suggestive interpretation
okay yeah probably i mean you know
people in harmonic analysis don't like
this interpret this t
notation they work with a very different
notation because they think of the heat
semi group of acting on the fourier
characters
um and so they use some
re-parametrization which is like
logarithmic in time
which makes perfect sense if you're
doing harmonic analysis and doesn't make
much sense if you're doing semi groups
okay so
um you can re-parameterize this integral
in many different ways but but
it's not going to change the answer
right or it's not going to give you any
new insight in it
okay thanks
there are other questions uh
yeah so i was wondering uh uh you you
made strong case for why
the constant and the trigger inequality
for a boolean function in the discrete
cube should be
absolute constant but it doesn't seem
like you said exactly what
is your conjectured value of that
constant and also i was wondering how
does it compare to the conjectured value
of the constant for
all real valued functions okay so these
inequalities are for all real valued
functions the ones i'm talking about
here
you see i mean the point this lemma over
here
right it's for any real valued function
my my point was that that this
inequality for real valued functions
actually is a much better inequality for
boolean functions than the puncher
inequality even though the tune the
quality when you phrase them for an
arbitrary real
your function look more or less the same
right so these are inequalities
good so let me write down you want the
conjecture so i'll just write it down
you you're froze by the way i'm not sure
if it's just me
yeah i also ramon your your screen has
stopped sharing
so you're awesome also you're muted
okay i don't know why that happened but
let me reconnect
it so um
in the gaussian case we have the analog
of this inequality with constant square
root pi over 2
um if you had it with the same constant
on the discrete cube then the gaussian
trigger inequality would just follow
from the central limit theorem
now we know how to get the gaussian
inequality from the central limit
theorem from pca right because we can
take the central limit theorem
in this theorem over here that will give
us the gaussian pca inequality and then
we can
apply that to get this l1 inequality but
that's not the same as having this uh
this conjecture
right then you're doing it in a
different order so
um i find it very likely that that the
constant is square root pi over two not
pi over two i mean okay we know that
this is not the same that
somebody once told me that it was
conjectured by jodrey i'm actually not
sure and i'm second guessing myself but
i'm just
just wondering i i've never heard judea
talk about this but uh um
um it's very possible i don't know um
but the conjecture is open what we know
is that this is actually true for
boolean
functions this inequality so for boolean
functions
the conjecture is true
it is a consequence of bobcoff's
inequality
okay so you can go from volcos
inequality to this conjecture for
boolean functions
but unlike in the continuous case in the
continuous case you can go back and
forth between set inequalities and
functional inequalities using the
co-area formula that doesn't work on the
discrete cube
and so um we know that this constant
squared pi over 2 is true for all
boolean functions
but but but we don't know that it's true
for um
for real valued functions i find it very
hard to believe that it's not true
but i mean i don't know who cares about
this constant square with pi over two in
this particular setting okay i don't
know whether that's an interesting
question in its own right
what's interesting about it to me is the
fact that we have all of these methods
of proving inequality in the discrete
cube and none of them seems to be able
to access this question
right so somehow we're missing something
about how to prove inequality in this
cube and this question is sort of a
symptom of this
about how to improve sharpen the
qualities on the screen
so um but i don't know if they conjure
you know if the conjecture is really
important in its own right i don't know
any application of this conjecture
but it's a very concrete question
uh ramona i think we're we are running
out of time so i'll ask you the last
question just very quickly
uh so clement asks uh does the theorem
for random occur
imply directly imply the same form for
regarding
and in that case does it lead to
anything new in the gaussian case or
does it does it retrieve pissier with a
different constant
i assume you're talking about this
theorem over here yeah
so um this theorem implies the gaussian
theorem with the same constant
so this theorem is sharp
it implies the gaussian theorem of pca
as is with the same constant and the way
you do it is you use the central limit
theorem you see if i have a function
from rn to r that you want to plug a
gaussian in rather than plugging a
gaussian in it plug in 1 over square
root n sum i is 1 to n of epsilon i
now it becomes a function maybe okay
maybe
take a big n right because each epsilon
i is a vector of dimension little n
so take many independent copies big n
and plug it in like this so by the
central limit theorem
if the function let's say is
sufficiently continuous this will
converge to the function of a gaussian
right and now just plug these functions
on the discrete cube of large and large
dimensions into this inequality
and you can check using the multivariate
the central limit theorem that pca is
inequality
for the gaussian will pop out with the
sharp constant and everything
so this car this this theorem is
strictly better than pcs in the quote
right p says inequality will follow from
us and so that also means this constant
pi over two over here
sharp because we know in the gaussian
cases um
now another thing you could do is you
could wonder why you know
you know pca proved it using rotational
variance of the gaussian but we
you know we use the semi-group argument
right so couldn't you do that for the
gaussian
right to prove it in the gaussian case
and the answer is yes you can start with
the original umbilic semi group and
repeat r proof verbatim and you will
also get a new proof of bca's inequality
right i think if pca had originally
proved his inequality using the ornstein
book semi group
this question would not have been a
question it would have been solved in
1986
right but you know um
but that's not you know pj uses
rotational variance and then you know
it seems so gaussian that it's not clear
what was going on right
but you you can both derive the gaussian
inequality from the inequality in the
cube by central limit theorem right
which shows that the inequality in the
cube is sharp and it's better
than the gaussian inequality um but you
can also repeat the proof
of the inequality on the cube using the
origemi group which is the right semi
group for the gaussian distribution
and give an alternative new proof of
pca's inequality directly using
semi-group arguments without rotational
environment
okay thank you very much so we will take
a quick break and then we will reconvene
at noon sharp for jalani's lecture